hi guys this is Rob from simply learn
and today we are going to be talking
about ten of the highest paying jobs in
2019 now without further ado let's jump
right into it at number 10 we have
project manager a project manager is
someone who's in charge of the overall
planning as well as execution of a
particular project a project managers
salary usually starts at around 91
thousand US dollars for a senior project
manager this can go up to one hundred
and twelve thousand US dollars now let's
have a look at some of the skills
required to become a project manager
firstly you need a strong understanding
of the strategic as well as operational
areas within project management you need
to know about leading-edge technologies
in the domain you need to be an expert
with each and every aspect of project
management from its initial stages all
the way to its completion and you need
to have experience when it comes to
handling large scale as well as cross
divisional projects the process of
becoming a project manager is also made
immensely easy when you have
certifications such as the PMP of the
project management professional
certification the prince2 foundation and
practitioner certification or the
certified scrum master certification now
let's have a look at some of the
responsibilities of a project manager
firstly you're in charge of planning
executing and closing projects you'll
need to handle teams and make sure that
there's commitment and productivity you
need to be able to manage expectations
and making sure that the project's
aligned with your business goals and you
need to be able to communicate the
project status the milestones you fit
and the difficulties you're facing to
the stakeholders now let's have a look
at some of the companies the regularly
hire project managers which is just
about every company in the world
there's Dell VMware HP ASAP Boeing eey
Adobe and so much more now let's have a
look at number nine full stack developer
a full stack developer works on both the
front end as well as the back end
portions of an application they earn
approximately 93 thousand US dollars per
annum a full stack developer has to have
the following skills they need to be
well versed in HTML CSS javascript node
or react or any angular framework they
need to know
one general-purpose programming language
B Ruby Python PHP c-sharp C++ and so on
they need to know about one relational
database system B Postgres MySQL Oracle
DB etcetera one web server like nginx or
Apache they need to know about one
deployment operating system be it
windows bun two-cent OS freebsd and so
on and have to have a clear
understanding of one version control
system like git SVN mercurial or any of
the others now let's have a look at some
of the responsibilities of a full-stack
developer firstly they are in charge of
designing as well as developing a
front-end UI they'll also have to do the
server-side coding they need to
integrate the front end as well as the
back end into the full stack and they
need to ensure that they lead the
project and work on it in such a way
that a good product is delivered to the
users now some of the companies that
regularly hire a full stack developers
are IBM Capital One horizon Microsoft
Splunk wig Pro PayPal and so much more
at number eight we have software
engineer a software engineer is one of
the most well known jobs in the IT
industry a software engineer develops
various applications that enable users
to accomplish tasks on their personal
computers and electronic devices they
earn approximately one hundred and
fifteen thousand US dollars per annum
now according to the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics software developer jobs are
expected to grow 17% from 2014 to 2024
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required for the role of a
software engineer firstly you need a
degree in software engineering computer
science or any other technical field
you'll need to understand as well as
master programming languages you'll need
to know about the different processes
that are involved in software
engineering and you'll need to have
logical as well as structure thinking
now if you're confused about what
programming language that you want to
learn next
I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the top 10
programming languages of 2019 now let's
have a look at some of the
responsibilities of a software engineer
firstly you'll need to analyze the
requirements of the users with respect
to a certain software you'll have to
create the software competence and May
oh they function properly you'll need to
work with different teams and oversee
deployment as well as maintenance and
you'll need to create instructional
material that'll enable users to use the
existing software now let's have a look
at some of the companies that regularly
hire software engineers which is again
just about every company in the world
there's Amazon Samsung JPMorgan
Microsoft Qualcomm Yelp Adobe Tata
Consultancy Services and so on now let's
have a look at number seven cloud
solutions architect the job of a cloud
solutions architect is one of the
hottest ones in the industry they plan
and design cloud environments and
provide guidance throughout the life of
a development or deployment project they
earn approximately one hundred and
twenty six thousand US dollars per annum
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
solutions architect you need to have a
good understanding of the various cloud
solutions that are provided by famous
cloud service providers like AWS
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud you need
to have hands-on experience when it
comes to designing available cost
efficient and fault-tolerant systems on
the cloud you'll need to have a whole
lot of practical knowledge when it comes
to using services within domains like
compute networking storage and database
and you'll need to be an expert in
deploying and maintaining cloud
solutions now let's have a look at some
of the responsibilities of a cloud
solutions architect firstly you'll need
to work to deploy your application on
the cloud architecture you'll need to be
able to migrate a company's physical
infrastructure onto the cloud you'll
have to focus on non-functional
requirements such as usability
scalability reliability and performance
and you'll need to make sure that you
are able to minimize risks for the
organization such as security leaks
calculation errors and application
downtime now let's have a look at some
of the companies they regularly hire
cloud solutions architects we have IBM
VMware Microsoft Amazon Google American
Express EA and so on that being said the
role of cloud solutions architect isn't
the only one you can find in the cloud
domain there's plenty of others to
choose from Asus office administrator a
DevOps engineer or a cloud developer at
number 6 we have IOT Solutions Architect
an IOT
solutions architects job is to do
whatever it takes to build an Android
IOT solution that solves real business
problems they earn approximately one
hundred and twenty-six thousand US
dollars per annum
now this isn't very surprising since the
International Data Corporation flix that
the worldwide Internet of Things
ecosystem and it's trends will continue
to see broad interest and momentum with
an expected market size of 1.5 trillion
dollars in 2020 now let's have a look at
some of the skills required by an IOT
Solutions Architect firstly you need to
clearly understand the particular
problem that IOT is solving you need to
be an expert in at least one programming
language like Python Java JavaScript or
C++ you'll need to know about
applications of IOT especially made
possible through edge devices and
sensors you need to have experience
working with miniature computers such as
Raspberry Pi and particle photons and
finally you'll need to have good user
interface creation skills now let's have
a look at some of the responsibilities
of an IOT Solutions Architect firstly
you're responsible for planning as well
as building and into an IOT solution
that solves real-life business problems
then you need to engage in continuous
learning about IOT businesses and its
data governance you need to help the
organization solve various business
problems by building discreet IOT
solutions and you'll need to set up as
well as communicate the overall IOT
vision the message and the architecture
to all of the stakeholders now some of
the companies that regularly hire IOT
solutions architects are Amazon Oracle
Nokia Hitachi Walmart skyworks
Accenture MathWorks and so on now let's
have a look at number 5 data warehouse
architect a data warehouse architect is
responsible for designing data warehouse
solutions and working with conventional
data warehouse technologies to come up
with plans that best support a business
or an organization they help in defining
strategy implementing plans and
delivering data warehousing a data
warehouse architect earns approximately
130,000 u.s. dollars per annum now let's
have a look at some of the skills
required by a data warehouse
architect firstly you need to be
familiar with data warehousing and the
ETL methodology which is the extract
transform and load methodology you need
to have an in-depth understanding of
data system and applications and
experience with client or server
web-based and server-side computing
architectures another thing that we
greatly helpful are additional
qualifications such as the certified
data management professional
certification that can help make you a
more valuable candidate in the job
market next up let's have a look at some
of the responsibilities of a data
warehouse architect firstly you'll need
to translate business as well as data
requirements into logical data models
now these data models need to adhere to
define data modeling standards as well
as industry best practices you need to
develop organization write architectures
and methodologies for software
application design and development
across multiple platforms you'll need to
understand and document the scope as
well as business requirements by
interacting and leading discussions with
stakeholders now let's have a look at
some of the companies that regularly
hire data warehouse architects there's
Wells Fargo Western Union Amazon
Facebook CGI Deloitte Accenture and so
on next up we have number four cyber
security engineer a cyber security
engineer protects information from theft
illegal duplication and unauthorized
access they deal with protecting
information on computer networks cloud
servers mobile devices and payment
software just to name a few a cyber
security engineer earns approximately
131 thousand US dollars per annum now
let's have a look at some of the skills
required by cyber security engineer
firstly you need to be well-versed in
languages such as dotnet Java Python and
C shop then you also need to know web
services like rest
and soap you need to understand how
cloud service platforms like AWS Azure
and Google cloud work and you need and
you need to have experience in
configuring as well as working with
security tools such as firewalls
antivirus software patch management
systems and so on you'll also need to
know about operating systems such as
Windows and Linux as well as a bit of
virtualization now let's have a look at
some of the rest
possibilities of a cyber security
engineer firstly you'll need to plan
implement manage monitor and upgrade
security measures for the protection of
systems networks and data you'll need to
monitor systems and networks to check
for intrusions or security breaches
you'll need to regularly conduct Network
scans to identify weaknesses of
vulnerabilities in the system you'll
need to develop automation scripts to
manage and track incidents and you need
to supervise as well as provide feedback
for changes in hardware software and
user needs now let's have a look at some
of the companies that regularly hire
cyber security engineer now this is one
of those jobs that just about every
company in the world will require
there's fidelity investments Moody's HP
Wipro Boeing and so on and now we're at
number three big data architect a big
data architect is an expert when it
comes to big data solutions such as
Hadoop and spark they earn approximately
130,000 US dollars per annum now let's
have a look at some of the skills
required by a big data architect firstly
you need in-depth experience in
developing data engineering solutions on
Hadoop and other related platforms you
need to understand the fundamentals of
traditional Hadoop systems clowder of
CDH and Hortonworks data platform you
need to have hands-on experience with
Hadoop HDFS yann MapReduce scoop hive
Impala and Apache spark and related
technologies you'll also knowledge about
ETL or the extract transform load
methodology and SQL we be an added
advantage now if you are interested in
taking up the job of a big data
architect you can look into
certifications such as the CCA spark and
Hadoop developer which is provided by
cloud era or the HTTP certified
developer in big data Hadoop by
Hortonworks
now let's have a look at some of the
responsibilities of a big data architect
firstly you'll need to manage the full
lifecycle of Big Data solutions such as
hadoop in apache spark you're
responsible for structuring and
analyzing the behavior of data you need
to be able to handle large-scale
databases analyze patterns of data and
make strong as well as accurate business
decisions you need to analyze system
bottlenecks benchmark systems
and propose solutions to eliminate them
you lead to document use cases solutions
as well as recommendations now some of
the companies that regularly hire big
data architects which is again a lot of
companies in the world
there's Nvidia Intuit GoDaddy JPMorgan
PayPal HP and so many more and now we're
at the top two at number two we have
data scientist data scientists are a new
breed of analytical data experts they
have the technical skill to solve
complex problems and the curiosity to
explore what problems need to be solved
they not only understand what problems
are solved they also figure out what
data is important how to acquire the
data to clean the data and extrapolate
information from this data they can
formulate a model or a theory
communicate the results with the
stakeholders and work with them to
translate results into business actions
they earn approximately one hundred and
forty thousand US dollars per annum now
let's have a look at some of the skills
required by a data scientist firstly you
need to be able to design develop and
execute solutions to business problems
you need to be an expert when it comes
to mathematical models numerical
analysis statistics and hands-on
experience with any programming language
you need to know how you can wrangle
data and visualize the results and need
to know the fundamentals of machine
learning algorithms and how you can
implement them now let's have a look at
some of the responsibilities of a data
scientists firstly you need to identify
problems related to data analytics that
offer opportunities for the organization
you'll need to collect large sets of
data and analyze this data so that you
can identify patterns trends and
insights you'll need to apply data
science methods such as machine learning
and statistical modeling you'll need to
communicate these findings to
stakeholders using visualization or
other means and you'll need to predict
forecast and drive data-driven business
decisions now some of the companies that
regularly hire data scientists are
Google Microsoft Goldman Sachs Netflix
IBM JPMorgan G Electronics uber and so
on now here's an interesting fact about
this role recent studies indicate that
there are more roles available than
there are skilled personnel which means
that the supply cannot
but with the demand this is a clear
indication that as long as you're
skilled there's plenty of opportunities
out there available for you and now
we're at number one
DevOps engineer a DevOps engineer works
with developers and the IT staff to
oversee code releases he or she
understands the software development
lifecycle and has the understanding of
various automation tools for developing
digital pipelines in continuous
integration and continuous delivery they
earn a whopping 144 thousand US dollars
per annum now let's have a look at some
of the skills required to become a
DevOps engineer firstly you need a clear
understanding of the DevOps life cycle
as well as DevOps tools you need to have
a strong understanding of programming
languages you need to know about
building coding testing integrating and
maintaining of a software project and
need to have experience working with
DevOps tools on cloud platform such as
AWS Google cloud and Microsoft Azure now
let's have a look at some of the
responsibilities of a DevOps engineer
firstly you'll need to work with
developers as well as the IT team to
oversee code releases you need to code
and script to ensure there's continuous
deployment as well as integration you'll
need to manage the IT infrastructure so
that you can support software code in
dedicated multi-tenant or hybrid cloud
environments you'll need to provision
resources you need to select the
appropriate deployment model and direct
the testing protocol to validate
releases and finally you'll need to
monitor the performance of the system
after the release is done now let's have
a look at some of the companies that
regularly hire DevOps engineers you have
Sony CGI Nvidia
NASA HP Lenovo Amazon and so on and with
that we've reached the end of this video
I hope this has inspired you to upskill
and grow in your career thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply lon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here